Please welcome Brent
Haley and Nick Offerman.
Uh,
thank you for honoring pride,
months decor,
Google colors.
That is right. Thank you guys both
for uh, for coming here today.
The movie opens tomorrow. Correct.
It opens tonight to narrow our,
there our preview
screenings, uh, this evening,
the movies playing at Regal Union Square
and that the landmark West 57 so you
can catch it starting tonight and
we'll be there offering whip crack
Rep parte, much like this. Correct nyquil
anyway. And they wouldn't be there,
but I'll be using foul language
because I won't have signed the, uh,
the Google contract. You are welcome
to use foul language. Here we are.
We're all adults in
the room. Thank you. So
I would love to get into the
history of the film. Brett,
you are the director and Co writer and
of course the Knicks executive producer.
And obviously we saw you're in
it, you played in it. Um, Brent,
probably your best to, to
start us off with this. How,
how did the concept of this movie
happen? How did this even get made? Uh,
well we've been wanting,
been wanting to do a, a movie in the music
space, the band space for a long time,
a big fan of that sort of sub genre
of movies. And so I was, you know,
I've had this idea for a
long time and my co writer,
Mark Bash and I had been talking about,
and we made a movie called the hero,
which with Sam Elliott and
nick was in that movie.
And after we worked with nick on that
film, I talked to mark and sort of said,
I think we found our dad for
that band movie we want to do.
I basically just wanted
nick to be everybody's Dad.
And uh, so we, we wrote that script
and we sort of developed it. We got,
we gave it to nick,
we premiered last year with the hero at
Sundance and we gave it to nick before
Sundance. And we're sort of
like, put this on your radar,
we want to make it this summer.
And we did,
we shot it in August and then it premiered
at Sundance in January and now it's
coming out in theaters. So it was
sort of a whirlwind, very quick thing,
but we worked very closely in the movie
is exactly what I intended it to be,
which is a feel good,
uh,
hopefully shot in the arm of just
sweetness and goodness and love.
And I was made out of a reaction to just
how kind of divisive and miserable the
general Twitter feed is right now.
So I,
that that was our goal and I think
we both went into it with the,
these intentions of just
spreading love and joy and music.
So that was the intent.
Nick, how did you, how did you, I
guess, fall love with this? Do you,
do you feel like you have to
have a personal stake in the,
in a script before you take
on a project? Well, uh,
I really had a great time working on
the previous movie, the hero with a,
with Brett and, uh, and I loved
his movie before that called,
I'll see you in my dreams with Blythe
Danner, Sam Elliott, Martin Starr.
Um, and so when they, you know, and,
and they work really fast.
Uh,
Brett has a really clear vision and I've
always gravitated towards independent
films because the artists usually gets
to have his or her say without the
corporate overlord saying, ah, Wah Wah,
how can we homogenize this
message? Um, put it in space.
And, um, and so I was already
a fan and I was on board, uh,
and then they said, we want,
you know, to write you,
we want to give you the Sam Elliott
treatment on this next movie.
And so I didn't really need to
see a script, uh, cause no one,
I mean I'm known I'm 47 and no one
has done that for me or with me.
Um,
but then when they gave me the script,
I was an incredibly gratified because
I haven't gotten to just play, uh,
you know, a human being that
we see go through, uh, the,
the banal scenes in his life,
you know, with vulnerability,
trying to figure out his conflicts,
trying to get his landlady to kiss him.
Spoiler alert, Toni Collette. If
Toni Collette was your landlord,
fair enough. Yeah. Right. You
might blush up a little walk.
And I think so collect the rent checks.
He mentioned that the character is very,
it is very human.
That was one of the things that,
that I would, that I was left with.
I've actually seen it twice already.
Um, super fan over here and watch out.
I want him to be my
dad. That's crazy. Yeah.
Even though yet I saw a screen yeah.
Screen a while ago after Sundance and then
I saw it recently to prepare for this,
but I walked away.
We,
everything throughout the whole movie was
very real to me in a way that a lot of
other movies I've seen habit been in.
A lot of it is because like,
I'm looking at some movies, like I
said, shot in space. So wrinkle in time.
Super unrealistic. Right. Swinging a miss
in the realism department. Yeah. So
I guess for both of you and nick,
how much of of the real you did you bring
to this versus like a Ron Swanson type
of character or maybe that is the real
you, I don't know you very well yet. Um,
and then, uh, Brett for you
too, when you were writing this,
you and mark were writing this, I mean,
you're using your sign in red hook.
We were talking backstage really that I,
everything was shot on location.
You had your opening party at the art
gallery and you're using real names and
real products.
How much of that was you guys and how
much it was just kind of by accident.
I'd want to step too
much on Brett's answer,
but that's the,
it's part of the answer to my,
to the last question as well,
which is a Britain is his writing partner,
market bash, write these really great,
realistic human stories. You know,
there's no, they're not high
concept. There's no big flashy hook.
It's like, here's some people
dealing with their shit and,
and usually love gets involved
and by the end you're like, oh,
well if we love each other,
maybe things will turn out okay.
Which is not a great elevator pitch.
These people a face, some, um,
some obstacles and they overcome
them or not via love. Yeah.
Lame. But I mean, I,
I suppose there's probably more of this
character's foibles and goofiness and
human failings. That's probably
more like me than Ron Swanson,
who is more of a superhero.
I mean,
he's kind of a cartoon character.
No mortal can eat that amount of red meat.
And also he can make an Irish harp
overnight drunk on whiskey. You know,
he's, uh, he's hyper real.
Um, but, but so for this,
I mean, uh, when, when
you get the script, uh,
and I've gotten to from Brett,
you're, the work has done for you.
Like they make it really easy for an
actor because you don't have to figure out
like, why am I doing this? You just have,
everything is woven into the scenes,
the backstories, very apparent.
Um, which makes it easy.
So I suppose it was out of laziness
that I ultimately chose to do this
fair.
Yeah. And just to piggyback
on that, I, mark and I the,
at least these movies that we've done,
and I think they're,
they go together very nicely.
I'll see you in my dreams.
The heroin and hearts beat loud and they,
they're all about just good people
trying their best and I think that there
needs to be more movies like this that
don't deal in in dread and tragedy and
just overwhelming circumstances.
There is some kind of unspoken rule that
for a movie to exist it has to be sort
of miserable in some way or it has
to be so big like you say in space or
superheros and that's kind of it.
To be an nd you've got to be this dark
and serious and an overwhelming thing and
I don't want that from the cinema.
I really wanted something like this
that felt good that that made you feel
things like people telling me like we had
our premier last night in red hook and
someone came up to, they're like,
I cried like 15 times this moving.
I'm not really sure why.
Like I wasn't sad but I just kept crying
and I think it's because people can
look up there and say, wow, this
is something that I can relate to.
We can all relate to the
idea of leaving our nest,
of leaving our parents to
go off to college. And we
as parents, we can say, Oh,
if I have a child that going
to be like when they leave,
we can all talk about the creative process
and what it means to create something.
Not for fame and fortune, but for
just the sake of creating something.
These are things,
you know,
and there's a beautiful love story at
the center of his film between Kirsi
Keirsey's character Sam and an actor
named Sasha Lane who plays rose.
It's a beautiful relationship.
It's a queer relationship.
It's between two women of color.
It or it's this things I'm not
seeing in movies like this.
And it's not a plot point.
It's not made to be something that is,
you know, fretted about
this dad rep, you know,
accepts and loves his daughter for
who she is, a queer woman of color.
That's something that I want to
see on screen. So you know, they,
cause to me that's real. So the,
the realism was at every turn of,
of creating this project was there to
create something that people could say,
I believe this. I buy this, this is real.
And you know what, it made me feel good.
That's the idea. Right. I really
appreciate it. That actually,
that exact thing that you're
talking about. I walked
away and it was like, yeah,
that whole story between salmon rosy,
it didn't matter that like you saw
it and it was just totally normal.
It wasn't like shaping the plot, which I
applaud you for. I think it was really,
really good.
Um,
but the main character is
struggling musician, um,
maybe still a child in his own right.
Uh,
did this character come from anyone
you know specifically or just kind of a
genre of just struggling red hook
musicians? Probably the latter.
And he doesn't come from any, anyone
that I know. He Shit. He certainly, uh,
frank shared some of my musical taste
and some of Nick's nick and I both love
Tom Waits on unhealthily and there's some
good Tom waits forever to Dan and Jeff
Tweety who,
spoiler alert makes a cameo in the
movie if you saw him up in the trailers.
So we love Jeff tweedy and Wilco and,
and all of Jeff's pans.
So there's definitely my
music nerdery is within frank.
But I think this idea of a,
someone who I love this theme of,
of someone who tried to do something
great and didn't quite get there.
It's a beautiful theme in a,
in a great Coen brothers movie called
inside Llewyn Davis. And it was,
it's something that is really appealing
to me, this idea of like, well,
I want to do this great thing. I didn't
quite get there. So what do I do now?
And then this little spark happens between
them where their song gets on Spotify
and frank is like,
maybe I can still get it.
And it's so it complicates
their relationship. So to me,
again, it's just tracking.
I think the reality of the, of
that character, right, to check,
have to get permission
from Spotify or oh yeah.
Don't really every album cover shown
in the film. Every song played every,
every reference. You have to get
permission. Yeah. I noticed the,
there's a couple of youtube videos
and like you got to get permission.
That was fun companies or persnickety
about you using their brand.
Apparently.
You would wonder why
modern phenomenon, Nikki, you
just want to give them some,
yeah. Hello. Right side. How's the back?
How's the neck line look and not good.
It's fine.
So you executive produced this,
is this the first I it in the first
time give you Pete something, correct?
No,
I,
I have executive produced and also
produced a handful of film projects on
different levels and it it,
you know, it's always, uh,
your title has producer in it.
It could mean a variety of things.
It could mean you kicked in money.
It could,
it could mean that you texted Ted
Danson and got him to be in the movie.
Um, did you do that? Oh
yes. That is actually,
I thought once a dental lab
that you were going to say no,
like just as like a thing. Like you
could have done that but you didn't,
but you did. I did. Yeah.
Um, yeah, that's, I mean that's
when you texted Jeff tweedy.
That's my main contribution. So Jeff
and Ted Danson could doers. Okay.
I'm going to, uh, I'm
going to lead with that.
Is that any different from what
you've done in the past? Why, I guess,
why decide to,
to put forth the extra effort and be an
executive producer when you're already
like the main focus of the show? Well, it
depends. It all depends on the project.
I mean, uh, if,
if I feel that I can be of
service basically and, uh,
uh,
a film of this size is my favorite size
because you can literally see everyone
making it together.
When you get on a big budget studio film,
you begin to feel more like a prop
kept in your air conditioned container.
And I'm like, okay, bring in
the bus driver, uh, for his,
you know, his three lines.
Um, and you know, you know, just the
prompts department is like 38 people and,
but I,
I liked to work with a group of people
small enough that I can learn everybody's
name and you can literally feel everybody
making this work of art together.
Um,
that's usually where I'm more likely
to come in as a producer on some level.
And in this, uh, I, I uh,
I did a lot less work than
all the producers. Um,
it has more to do with me
helping cast it. Uh, and I,
I take a morale very seriously.
I,
I try to act like the team
captain, you know, um,
I got us cool tee shirts.
Tis true the two two,
two tee shirts or red hook records,
tee shirt and a Sonny's bar t shirt for
day one of the shoot there were Sunny's
we were shooting at Sonny's and there
were boxes of Sonny's bar t shirts waiting
for everyone.
And that's the kind of Guy Nick is.
That's the kind of tone that he
sets on a film like this. There's,
there's no to do that.
He bought us.
How many ice cream trucks did you get us,
but I mean to in any cause I ate a lot
of ice cream because that's the idea.
It was a good ice cream.
You're basically a traveling Google
about tee shirt. That's high
praise. I don't know if I can,
if I can spell all of that.
Half my dresser is Google tee
shirts that I've never bought.
My algorithm might be
somewhat simpler than,
but I feel like I could
ask you almost anything and
I'll take a swing at it. Fallible. Google.
Um, so you mentioned you
touched on the rest of the cast.
So this is Ted Danson 20 clip life. Dan
Life Danner, of course. Kiersey Clemons.
Amazing, amazing actress.
She's on the up and up. Really?
Like how did you find you fixed it?
You literally,
you literally texted a couple of these
people and they said, don't do this,
but how did you find Kirsi? How did that
come across? I mean, I've known, I've,
I've been following Keirsey's
star for years. I mean,
I've been aware of her certainly since
dope, if not before. Dope. Great.
Mommy called Dope Sundance three
years ago. Yeah. Was there when,
I'll see you in my dreams were there,
so 2015. So I've been, I've been,
she's been on my radar and I think she's
a superstar. She was in transparent.
She was in a easy, which is on
Netflix. Um, she kind of do it all.
And when I discovered that she could,
she could sing,
I did some deep diving and I sort of
found some like deep cut clips of her like
doing grease in high school
playing sandy. And I was like, oh,
this girl can sing. And I'm a huge fan of
her. Uh, and we were nearing, we had had,
you know, we were, it's very hard
to find the person to play Sam.
I knew I wanted her to be
biracial. I knew, you know,
it was just trying to find the right
person who could sing, who could act,
who had the right vibe with nick.
And Sasha was cast at that point
and Sasha and Kirsi are friends.
And when I found that out I was like,
oh, we, we need to make this happen.
And I just called Nick and I said, I've
got a really good feeling about Kirsi.
Are you cool if I just make the offer?
And we made the offer?
And she said yes the same day.
So it was something that she just,
I think because of Sasha and because of
that, it was very easy to go like Sasha,
nick, Ted, Tony, bleive and me. Sure.
I'll do that. Read script. Yeah.
And it's an 18 day shoot in Brooklyn.
I can handle that. You know,
it was not a big end.
She,
I knew she wanted to do something in the
music world and get herself out there.
And now it's like we've made
a movie. We've also made a
record. It's very meadow,
what's going on because our record
comes out tomorrow on Vinyl.
It will be on Spotify, iTunes, that'll
be everywhere. Who play Google play.
Thank you. Where are
we right now? Um, yeah.
Have Google play that too.
Um,
but it is exciting that we've made
this album, you know, like nick and,
and Kirsi sing all the songs, performed
all the songs and, and, and um,
it's crazy. So I think it's amazing cause
cause she has such a dynamic quality.
Uh, she's uh, she's a, and
when you see you're here,
see her and then hear her
saying you're like Whoa, it's,
and all the vocals in the movie are
live. I was going to, we're not,
we're not doing like in the trailer
and stuff that's, that's play,
that's like kind of lip
sinking in the movie itself.
When you hear the song being recorded,
when you see them perform, it's,
it's coming through the
actual mic that we did onset.
So nick plays a whole song on Acoustic
Guitar and sings live in one take.
It's beautiful and very, very sweet.
And so that was also going back to the,
to the realism was was making sure
that the audience bought this,
this we're not a band is a real band
and that it sounded and felt really real
and not just like a music video where
people are kind of lip sinking. Yeah.
You can often tell when people are like
strumming and it doesn't quite, yeah,
we had to do some of that just because
filmmaking is limited in what you can
record.
And I put everything towards towards the
vocals to make sure we got live vocals
on set.
So sometimes you've got actors,
literally they have earwigs and there
is these little ear pieces that are
playing the songs and nick and Kirsi
have them. I have them in my headphones,
there's like 30 extras.
No one can hear the music and nick and
Kirsi just have to sing and play pretend
play and, and like sing acapella.
And the audience is like,
yeah,
this is so good as her,
it's really awkward but I'm like dancing
cause I can hear it in my headphones
and everyone's like, this guy's
crazy. But he's, you know,
that's the kind of stuff you have to
do to make it, to make it seem real.
You know, you don't, you know, I took
cues from inside Llewyn Davis and,
and other movies that I think
did it right. So we, we,
we did our best on our small budget and
schedule them to do it that way. Oh,
it was wonderful. And then the songs
themselves, she can do it. Compose,
he could most all of it. Right. He did
with a little help from his band mate. Uh,
Jeremy Bullock, he was a,
he was our onset coach,
taught nick how to play the electric
guitar, helped him through, you know,
how to do that. And he contributed
some to a few of the songs. But yeah,
Keegan is a pretty good,
pretty good at what he does.
I was listening to his 2009 album,
like his standalone have
nothing to do with this,
like all day on repeat yesterday.
So you know, it's a very good tone.
It fits the movie. And then the
heartbeat beat love the title track.
He wrote that in 2010 right? It was a
long time ago. It was a long time ago.
It was a version. It was a version of it
a long time ago. And I love the title.
Like, it's always stuck with me and I
loved the kind of ear warm quality of it.
It doesn't have a proper chorus,
it just builds. And then I'm,
I'm sorry you guys had
to hear it on repeat.
It's going to be stuck in
your heads all day. Um,
but it has that great kind of quality.
And I bought it as something that she
could write kind of in a day. So we,
we, we started reworking that and figuring
out how that would sound in this movie
with a female vocal and, and, and
I just bought it as like Guitar,
like Dad rock meets cool,
new young hip, electronic,
Indie pop rock, you know, like,
it felt like a good mix of those things.
Like Red Hook. Yeah. Yeah. More or less.
And Nicky said, or he said that you
had to learn the electric guitar.
Do you know what,
what instruments did you know before this?
Um, the, uh, the unplugged guitar.
I mean, that, that's my main instrument
these days is the Acoustic Guitar,
which I play as a humorist. Um, so,
but I had never played electric before and
it was, uh, it was difficult. I mean, I,
uh,
the stuff I play is pretty rudimentary
and foci and so just to play like rifts
up the neck, uh, it was like
learning to dribble, um,
because my hands didn't know how
to do what was required of them.
Uh,
but Jeremy was a great coach and I had
had enough time and I'm old enough to
know that you have to put in your
practice on the fundamentals. And so,
but at the time we shot,
I was able to actually play all the stuff
I was supposed to. Um, and I, you know,
I grew up playing the saxophone.
I play a little bit of a lot of stuff,
but no one ever asks me to,
he plays drums and bass and guitar,
Acoustic and electric in the
movie. So He's, he does it.
He does it all. Almost all.
We didn't get him on the Sax. He's
kind of done that before. Yeah.
Thank Kirsi plays a synth.
Yeah. She had, he had a sampler,
the Ableton push and the, and the, and the
keys. Yeah, I mean it was that all real,
what she was doing as well was like
you were trying to replicate it
authentically. Totally. Like everything.
I learned all about Ableton, Ableton push.
It was like a whole new world for
me about how to sample and how to,
how to create a sample. Like she's not
like taking samples from other songs.
She's creating the sample on the
keyboard, recording it, playing it back.
So what we learned a lot and you see that,
you see that creative process in the
film, you see how these, you know,
you can create such incredible stuff by
yourself and your bedroom these days and
record it and put it on Spotify.
That's kind of the idea or Google play.
And that's sort of the idea behind
the movies that you can kind of create
anything now with technology. You can
go make a movie, you can make a song,
you can, you know, and get it out
there to the world. And if it's good,
it's got a shot. Yeah, it
was absolutely incredible.
And I love breaking it down like this
and I'm more of a behind the scenes kind
of person. And I love watching
it all builds, like in the movie,
it just all comes together and
it works. Um, and then it's like,
what's our band name and we're not a band.
Okay, cool. Let's go with that. Yeah.
And uploading and Spotify
immediately. Yes. Right. Um,
what were the rehearsal process is
like when you first came in the room?
Like was it you and Kirsi and Keegan
and the were all just like, all right,
here we go. Let's do this. Uh, Keegan
wasn't there at the beginning. Jeremy,
right for me
was, um, and uh,
that was when Keirsey first arrived.
We had a few days of rehearsal
before we started shooting.
And so she blew into the room.
We had been rehearsing with Blythe Danner,
who plays my mom.
Um,
and Kirsi blew in and just started hugging
everybody and it was like a Rainbow
Unicorn had gal into
the room. And I mean, I,
I can't say enough about Kirsi.
I think this movie would have
been really good without her.
And with her, it's sublime. Like
she's, she's just exceptional. Um,
she's such a personality
and such a beautiful soul.
And then she starts singing and your hat
just flies off and you're like, oh shit,
this is it. You guys got
really lucky. Yeah. Yeah.
So, you know, we, uh, we,
we were very gently coach w we both have
musical skills to the level that we do,
but there's a,
there's an element of,
of superhero origin story because
through the filmmaking, you know,
I can play a drum set, but they
make me look like I can play a song.
Like we create a song like a Keegan
Dewitt song and that's a super power where
it's like, oh yeah, what do
you think about this? As,
as though I can casually come up with
those riffs, which I can't, you know,
that's what I, it was really fun
to see the movie and be like,
I seem like a kick ass musician
and it's really fun. See
that this scene where they're coming
up with heart, speak loud and,
and see him playing the ref
and see Kirsi plane, the keys.
That's all happening in camera.
That's all real.
And we allow that to be really organic
and let them kind of put their spin on it
when they discover your melody
meets my melody and Oh that,
that really works. It's, it's pretty fun.
And Keirsey's really playing the keys
and all that stuff when they're kind of
being inspired and figuring out the
tunes and the melodies and stuff. It's a,
that was again, a big part of it
for me just to be like, yes, they,
they're doing this, this is actually
happening. Well, um, well cool.
So if anybody has any questions,
you can start letting up now and
I'll continue to talk here. Uh,
I guess we'll go back to the
location for a little bit. We've,
it's obviously a red hook. We've talked
about that a couple of times. Why,
why Red Hook and why these specific
locations that you found? Well separate a,
I'll let nick tell his
connection to red hook,
which I didn't know at the time
when first when we didn't, uh,
we didn't know Nick's
connection to Red Hook,
but I live in cobble hill
and I have for 13 years.
My wife and I lived there and I've
just always walked to red hook.
It's just what I do. I walk over to
Red Hook. When I first moved to, uh,
to New York, I lived right on the
edge of Red Hook in Carroll Gardens,
like right on the BQE. It
was really nice. Um, so I,
I just would walk over there and I'd go
to Sonny's and I'd just walk around the
piers and I just loved the feeling and
it, it's sort of like this own weird, uh,
beautiful and eclectic thing. And in
Brooklyn that's its own thing. It's,
it's Brooklyn, but it's red hook. It's
totally, it's, it's, it's something.
And so there's just,
we wanted, we've been,
mark and I had been wanting to
set a tail there for a long time.
We did write another script that was
no good, that took place in red hook.
And we thought with this one,
hey,
why don't we have it take
place in red hook and go full.
And it was great to shoot it baked and
she sunnies and just out on the street
and called this record store red
hook records. It was really fun. Um,
so that's why you know that it's
like kind of like home to me.
We shot in Cobble Hill and red hook
almost the whole movie a little bit in
Greenpoint, but that was pretty
much, yeah. You know your
neighbors. Yeah, it's good.
It's good stuff. Well, and then nick,
what your connection to red oaks?
Really interesting, I think. Yeah.
So they did this and handed me the
script and unbeknownst to them,
10 or 11 years ago,
my wife was doing young Frankenstein on
Broadway and we were living on the upper
west side. And, uh,
the only caveat to her taking that job
was I had to leave my woodshop in Los
Angeles for a year and a half. And I
said, good. I, uh, I'll leave my clients.
I've been wanting to build
my first wooden canoe,
this will give me the chance to do that.
So I brought a bag of chisels and hand
planes with me as one does as one does.
And uh, this, uh, you know,
it took a little time to
get through Tsa, but I, I'm,
I'm charming.
Uh,
and so I got here and I looked around
and the only affordable shop I could find
was in red hook and one of those big
old brick warehouses down below at the
bottom of Van Brunt.
Uh, the super cool, uh,
would co op and I got this shop out.
The window was perfectly
the statue of Liberty.
It was a super romantic and dreamy.
And I built my first canoe there
also Ron Swansons first canoe, um,
named huckleberry and, and baked.
I stopped at every morning.
I rode my bike there every day from
the upper west side and just had this
incredibly romantic year and a half
as though I was in on the waterfront,
which is set in red hook. And, uh,
and I baked and Sonny's
were two of my spots.
So it was just a wonderful piece of
serendipity when I read the script and was
like, oh, this is me.
I love their biscuits.
Picked baked, not knowing
that he went through all the
time. I, yeah, Sonny's Bay,
all of it. I had no clue. He, we sat
down in La, we had lunch together and I,
and we had read the script and he's
just like, dude, like I built my first,
he knew in red hook,
like I'm so connected to this place.
So there's some kind of magic there.
It's like I, I knew in my heart,
like I wouldn't have made this movie
without nick. Like when we met and I,
we wrote it with him in mind and it was,
so there's something obviously
kind of Kismet e about that, that,
that he had that connection
to and we didn't even know
that. So he's like, he was,
he was made for this, this
role, you know. Yeah. I agree.
I love how he keeps saying his first canoe
because he's built more than one. Um,
yeah. Let's take a question over here. Uh,
my question is more about like your
roles in sort of like how they fit into
culture because a lot of your
roles are like very masculine,
but they're also super
positively masculine.
So I just wonder like how you feel about
your sort of status is like a super
awesome masculine character to like change
how a lot of people feel about it and
create more positive
masculinity in the world.
Well, thanks. So the, the,
there are some nice compliments
laced into that question. Uh,
I, uh, I have great parents. Um, I uh,
was brought up with good manners and,
um,
and I love performing, you know, stories.
I tried to pick things that are
medicinal in some way for the audience.
And so, uh, through
good fortune, you know,
I've landed some roles that,
uh,
I've seen the audience
accusing me of masculinity. Uh,
and it's a weird thing to be accused
of because often certain sects of the
audience are a little more narrow
minded or a little more old fashioned.
And so when they say masculinity,
it's a little gross or it's
a little old fashioned,
it's laced with misogyny or
bullying or just a, you know,
a general, a sense of, of testosterone.
And so I dunno,
uh,
given the opportunity to speak to that,
I try to steer people in the other
direction and usually if a, if I,
anything I say sounds like good
advice. Uh, I'm usually the, the, uh,
intended target more than
anybody. Um, and so, you know,
regardless of what people ask me when
they say like, how should a man behave,
I kind of answer with my present
sensibility of how should a person behave
because men are a part
of the group of people.
And I, uh, I believe we should
all be nice to each other and,
and treat everyone as equals,
you know, across the board.
And that's my starting point.
I am also aware that I'm human,
therefore a dip shit.
Uh, and so that's why I'm the,
the first intended target. It's,
it's something we'll never
be done getting better at.
And so we should always keep talking
about it, especially in front of a,
a rainbow colored curtain.
My pleasure.
That's the quote from today as I'm
human. Therefore a dip shit. Oh yeah.
Question over here
is first off,
awesome casting with mayday Malone as
a bartender in this movie. I love it.
Um, I have a personal question
for things that I like to create.
I'm actually going to be building a two
benches for my fire pit this weekend.
I would love to have a
couple of words of advice.
I'll take this one
first.
Would hammer nails good luck.
Now,
take it from the master here.
Um, well first of all, I, uh,
my wife, uh, Megan Mullally, who's
on the program will and grace,
uh,
on television,
she also played Tammy to on parks
and rec was like just in case.
Yeah. Case they didn't
know. Yeah. Ps, if you're,
if you haven't been to Nancy and
beth.com that's the tip of the day.
That's her band. She'll
knock your socks off. Uh,
last night she saw the movie
for the first time and, and uh,
still slept in my bed,
which I take is a great compliment.
She said that Brett so good at,
uh, at making his movies seem real,
which is such a great compliment from
her. She has, she has really, uh,
exacting artistic taste.
So it's,
I was terrified sitting next to her
watching the movie. Yeah, he teaches,
he texted me like,
so Megan's going to see the movie
tomorrow and now it's real for me.
It's was like, yeah. Um, but,
but she also said, uh,
bread is so good at casting.
And that's why I wanted to
reiterate that because it's,
it's something that you
can take for granted,
but when somebody has a knack for it,
uh, it makes all the difference. Um,
I don't know what, uh, your
benches are made out of, but I'll,
I'll suggest that you take your time.
Uh,
go to work sober measure twice,
uh,
so that you can cut once and
if you're using bladed tools,
make sure they're properly sharpened.
Thank you very much.
Past your tools wisely over here.
Hi,
I'm so broad.
I know you already touched upon the
queer elements of this movie a bit and I
just wanted to say thank you for including
that in the narrative because uh,
it was really refreshing to read about
this movie and hear that there were queer
women who got to survive throughout
the movie cause that's not typical. Um,
and I think a lot of times movies fall
into those harmful tropes because there's
just not queer women involved in
the production of the film. Um,
so my question is how influential work
here and Sasha and kind of gunning to
like sculpt their characters and
sculpt the narrative of the movie.
Thank you for that question.
And I do want to talk a little bit about
going back to the masculinity thing,
going back to what it means to be a white,
straight male in society and the
privilege that comes with that and
acknowledging that privilege
and understanding that as
part of that privilege,
we must be putting other
people in things and on, in,
in media that represent the
reality of these situations.
Not as a plot point,
not as a trope,
not as something to be pushed away
or, or, oh my God, here, what,
what is that? Oh, what is like sort
of doing that, which is so ridiculous.
And it was always my goal to have a queer
relationship in this film and treat it
with no sort of posts.
Just saying this is like
any other summer romance,
which it is any queer person,
any trans person,
doesn't sit around going all
day. Oh God, I'm this. I'm that.
They just live their lives.
And that's what I wanted these characters
to be able to do. And by total chance,
when Kirsi and Sasha came on board,
they both opened up to mark and I and
said, you know, we identify as queer.
And I said,
well,
tell me exactly how I
can make this better.
How did we do? And they said, you did
pretty good, but they're talking about it.
We don't talk about it. We don't sit
around talking about how we're queer.
We just love each other and kiss
and enjoy the summer together.
And it was a really big moment. And so
we went through each scene with them.
We spent a half a day with just Kirsi
and Sasha and mark and I being educated.
Tell me, tell me how you would
want to see this on screen.
And we did something that a lot of
white men should do more. We listened.
And so I hope that you will see this
film and I hope that it will move you.
And I hope that anyone of of any,
any race,
any gender, any sexuality, sexual
preference, whatever it may be,
can just see a beautiful love story
between these two characters and move on.
And that's why I'm so proud. I'm so,
the thing that I'm also so proud of,
his health,
Frank's character,
Nick's character of frank responds to it
and it's, I don't want to give it away.
I want you all to go see it.
It,
it really is kind of quietly
radical when you don't judge,
when you don't make it something
that's bad or something,
that punishment is
waiting around the corner.
It's just love and embracement
and that's what we need.
And that was my goal.
And obviously I could not have done it
as well as it has done in this without
Kirsi.
And Sasha,
it's so important to listen to the
people whose stories that it is,
especially when you have the
privilege that I have, I don't under,
I have to acknowledge that I do not know
what it's like to be in the shoes of
someone else.
So listening was key and I owe
them a ton for that. Thank you.
Wonderful. Thank you. Um,
I have a fun question though. Not
that, that was fun. Oh, sorry.
I was super fun.
Fun.
I've always wanted to know.
And in movies where you see
old pictures of the actors,
where do those pictures come from?
We see a wonderful album cover of,
oh man,
that one beard.
He submits Sukus busted glass night.
He saw that it's his old,
that's
his old headshot, which
is infamous. Just Google,
nick Offerman young
headshots and wait for it.
I'm not going to give it away, but
no, nick gave me a ton of photos. Um,
and,
and we,
and we photo shopped and then there's
a great playbill of Ted Danson.
Uh, and a status status quo. Vadis yes.
And that is real.
That is from a production
that he did on Broadway.
The only time Ted was on Broadway
and it closed in one night,
which fits the character and fit. I
didn't know that though. I was like, oh,
we're going to use this,
that play that he was in on Broadway
and then Ted was like, yeah,
we did one night I came back to the
theater and the security guard was like,
what are you doing here? And he was like,
I'm going to work. And he was like, no,
you're not. He did fine. You guys,
you guys are like, Oh, poor ted. He, he
did pretty good. Yeah, it worked out.
I think so. [inaudible] I love
putting that stuff in again,
making it as real as possible. And we did
some trickery to make, to pull off, uh,
his wife in the film and
make sure that it kind of,
I think they turned out pretty
well. Yeah. I mean, we, uh,
Brett cast a great actress
and we did a photo shoot,
like, you know, which is that,
that's a testament to you.
It would be,
it would have been very
easy not to have paid, uh,
an actress and instead just gone
into, you know, the world of,
of images on the,
the Google location on the computer.
Um,
but we didn't, yeah, we can, we
cast an actor and you made the,
put him in like nineties and early 2000
clothes and like the found pictures of,
of Nick and then recreated the way
he was in that photo. So he, he,
it was his body and then we took his
head from the other photo and put it on
with the act. So it looks,
it looks really great.
It has sort of a very authentic quality.
At least we, we, we did our best. Yeah.
No facial hair. Nick always takes
me for a loop, but it's okay.
I'll take that as a compliment. Thank
you. Yeah, we're not used to it. Um, yeah.
Question over here.
Hello.
My question is basically
going from being in a,
on a show that has like many seasons
and be on those actors for a really long
time.
Uh,
what's the difference between having
like a smaller project and do you see
yourself kind of going more into the
indie route or is this something that like
you're just still playing
around with other things or?
Um, well, it's interesting. I, you
know, if you're lucky enough to get,
get on to a series a period,
you're, you've won the actor lottery. Um,
because the hardest thing for an
actor is just to get a damn job. And,
and you know,
the term starving actor
is a become commonplace.
Uh, you're lucky enough to
get on a series. That's good.
That's good writing then that's like
winning the lottery among the lottery
winners. Uh, and um,
and so something on parks and rec
is such an such a dream a moment.
Because if I'm trained in the theater,
so you know,
I get cast in a play, I, you
know, I get a script that's,
you know,
somewhere around two hours long and you
learn it and then you'd do it for maybe
some months, um, on a, on
a TV show like that. Uh,
you get cast and,
and maybe they have a few,
a handful of episodes
written, but if it goes, uh,
you all together get to create
the lives of these characters.
And it's really gratifying because
these really smart writers, uh,
they deserve most of the credit, uh,
have the wherewithal to say, okay,
we're, you know, season four, where
are we going to take these people?
And, you know, uh,
they came up with such positive,
beautiful and hilarious things
for us to do. And so that's,
to get to do that for seven years
is just beyond. I, you know, it's a,
it's an incredible,
um,
but it doesn't feel very different
than working on a film like this.
It's just a different duration. Uh, if,
if for some reason a
channel like a or a website,
I don't know if you, if you
know any computer companies, um,
if they called Brett and said,
we love your movie,
how would you feel about making a
hundred episodes of it or something,
I'm available. Then it would
be the same for me to be like,
oh, we're going to keep, we're gonna
keep following frank in his life.
And it's a,
I don't know if my wife and I both
choose our projects based on our,
our feeling that the writing is good and
is somehow going to help us evolve or
at least make us laugh a uncontrollably.
Those are the parameters.
Uh,
cause I don't know if children's
hospital is particularly revolutionary,
but we thought about, we thought it
was super funny and we do thought,
we did think that it breaks down rules of,
of what comedy can be.
Um, but I don't, uh,
I don't have any particular ambition.
Uh,
whatever the next good
writing that comes in.
It could be for the stage for
the F it could be indie film,
could be studio movie.
But probably not because they're usually
not as good writing because they've
been through corporate. It's art by
committee. Um, or it could be a TV series,
whatever. I, I'm not particular, uh,
as long as I can spend
some time in my woodshop,
I'll be happy to show up and be
in your project always. Cool.
Thank you. If we got time for two more
questions, let's take this one. Hi. Uh,
so I don't know how like twiddly a movie
dose, three hours, something like that,
but going from audience to the Sundance
in January and do an 18 days to shoot,
did it feel very rushed?
Does it feel
no, all the time in the world.
I'm just kidding. I'm just
kidding. Yeah. Yeah, it was,
it was very rushed.
Crazily fast. It was gnarly. Did,
do you feel like you kind of miss
something or do you feel like you kind of
wanted to put something else in
you? You, you always do. I mean, I,
I can't, not at not a healthy, um,
cabi to look back at the movie and
go, man, I should've done this.
And I wish that one scene was like that
I made the movie I wanted to make and
that and that's because I was told,
hey, you're going to have 18 or 19 days,
you have this much money,
here's where you can shoot it,
that these scenes need to take
place in these locations. Good luck.
And so I knew,
I knew what I was going into and mark
and I knew and so we worked that into the
script to ensure success,
at least for the level of success at
this movie is going for it. It is.
People sometimes call my film small films.
I don't mind that at all.
It doesn't bother me in any way to call
my movie a small film because it might
be, it might, it was quick, it was cheap,
it was a little scrappy, but it has,
the themes within it are,
are big,
are the biggest ones that we talk about
love and a father and a daughter and
creation and dreams and grief. These
are, these are not small things.
These are big things and you
just kind of go, you know,
it's like I finished the movie on August
31st I knew I had to submit to Sundance
at the end of September. I didn't
want to have to work, you know,
seven days a week with my editor, 18
hour days. I didn't want to do that.
My wife's certainly didn't want me to
do that. And Patrick, my editor's wife,
who has a kid, he, she, she wasn't happy
with me for 18 days or for the month,
but we did it, you know, we pulled it
together. We got to cut to Sundance.
Thankfully they loved it.
We got in and we finished the movie
by Christmas and turned it around.
But it's all very fast.
I mean,
the movie is going to be out to the
world and kind of kind of boom, poof,
before the one year anniversary of a
shooting it. But that's great. That's,
I love that pace.
You know,
once you work on something for
a really long period of time,
for me as a director,
you can get a little lost in it.
Unless we want to do heartbeat loud,
the TV series I will give,
I will give a hundred episodes for
that. I'd be very happy to do that. So,
and I would like to add a couple things.
One is that Britt,
it was incredibly fast,
but Britain, uh, I,
I don't imagine he ever felt rushed
because he knows what he's doing is a very
clear vision.
And there were things in the script there.
There was a very romantic scene where
I was riding my bicycle over the East
River,
probably on the Manhattan bridge.
And I was like, oh my God,
they're going to shoot me riding a
bicycle. It was like the sky and you know,
it'll be around shit. Yeah. And, um,
and immediately like,
you know,
as soon as the line producers started
laying out the schedule, they were like,
okay, that's cut. Uh, and
we were like, ah, okay. But,
but when I was doing, and
I'll nutshell this, when,
when I was doing theater in Chicago,
I learned this lesson that I think
really applies to art of this size.
My theater company was very broke and
we did a car chase between a cop car and
some bad guys with these two cars that
were built out of like refrigerator boxes
and with great paint jobs.
And we had s cocaine stage hands.
It's a Kabuki convention.
People in black robes like shoving the
cars around and with sound and acting
and, and this, uh, convention,
the audience totally was got what we
were doing and life was with it and like,
Oh shit,
you know,
a fruit cart came out and
God tamable ass over tea cup.
And then at the same time,
some friends were in a play at a big
great theater company in Chicago.
And in this play somebody
wrote a motorcycle on stage
and made us cool entrance
on a Harley.
And I went and saw this play and I just
really noticed the difference between
when you have the budget to be like,
let's fucking ride a motorcycle on stage.
It's, it's briefly, uh, and
superficially impressive,
but there's no magic involved. So
you're like, Whoa, that's loud.
That's a real motorcycle on
stage. Okay, that's over.
But when you involve the audience in
the Mechan mechanization of creating
whatever the magic of the storytelling is,
it's so much more satisfying and I
just think it makes better art to place
limitations on it so that way
I'll have to work together to say,
let's tell a story. This is a rabbit,
you know, and it, and everyone's like,
okay, I'm with you. Then we're together.
Where as opposed to being like,
check out this fucking rabbit,
I need to limit the limitations
that are put on me constantly.
As a filmmaker.
Do you bring out the best in you because
you have to say what is essential to
tell this story appropriately.
You, you can't be like, well,
like you said, like, oh,
we can do this.
We did.
You end up wasting a lot of time on stuff
that you're like, well that's pretty,
but it doesn't really
help move the story along.
So you mark and I were like forced to go.
What really is going to help this
movie. So I, I don't, I don't mind it.
I would certainly take more money and
more days to make a movie. I mean,
if anybody's giving those
out. Thank you. Thank you.
Final question real quick.
You mentioned,
you talked about how you all about the big
happy positivity to
counteract today's world,
but then you mentioned inside Llewyn
Davis a couple of times as an inspiration,
which I feel like is not exactly
that. Yeah, that movie's not,
I'm curious what you took from that
movie and if there are any other music
centric movies that you took
his inspiration for this
one. Absolutely. Yeah. No,
this is certainly not inside Llewyn Davis.
I think it does share that theme of being
good but not great and not having made
it and what that means and the Coen
brothers movie certainly goes in a much
different direction than than ours does,
but I think they actually have similar
outcomes because it, it, it, again,
this is not the rocky battle of the bands
movie where they go and get fame and
fortune. This movie's not about
that going after that star.
Can you find happiness if your
dreams don't come true? Correct.
That's what it's about.
And I think inside Llewyn Davis,
Llewyn Davis is having
a very difficult time.
I think our characters do find some kind
of peace and happiness and love within
failure or within coming up short
of what someone's goal was. I mean,
I'm fascinated by that. Just as an
artist, as a person with aspirations,
what does it mean to be satisfied
by said art is the doing of it.
Enough itch it should be.
It's hard to not put success and money
and fame and all that bullshit on top of
it. But that's what I'm
after. And so the, the real,
the real movies that tonally I think we
mixed in and sort of a blender for this
would be high fidelity,
that thing you do,
which I adore. Um, and once probably,
and then there's a great Japanese
film called Linda, Linda,
Linda about an all girl band.
That's incredible.
So I would say those five
movies with Lou and Davis,
she kind of in a blender also.
Then the music man.
And West side story, you know. Um,
but I think that that kind of blend
of the realism of once and the joy,
like that thing you do is not a,
again,
it has the feeling that I think this
movie has where you can watch it and just
go, yeah, I knew that that was, that
made me feel good. There's, there's,
there isn't anything tragic that's
going to happen. You're not,
the filmmakers not going to knock you
in the face when you turn the corner.
It's just kind of taking you on this
journey, showing you beautiful characters,
interactions, what it means to
have gone through something.
And that is 100% the
goal. And I, you know,
anytime you open a movie and you start
looking at the reactions and it's like,
this is what we wanted to do and,
and I hope that you all will go check
out the movie because there is conflict
and there is resolution.
Thank you. Thank you.
Cool.
Everybody help me thank them for it.
Thank you.